[Music]
on today's show we talk about some heavy
themes so watch out for the little ears
in the room we talked to a young man who
has a friend who appears to be a
pedophile he doesn't know what to do we
also talked to a woman who followed her
dream and her husband and they bought a
farm and now she's lonely stay tuned
[Music]
say you
save me
save for all i think it's safe for
always is that how that song goes i
don't know how that song goes this is
john with the dr john daloni show i'm so
glad you're with us that's how it goes
say it for always we're laughing because
you started another older show the exact
same way did i write exact same way yes
sometimes these songs get stuck in my
head on a loop and i don't know where
they're from i don't even know how they
go but there you go and i told you in
the previous show that it was from a
movie called white knights
oh yeah it's all coming together now
we do too many shows
we should go to one a month i think
there's or you'd have two narrow tastes
one or the other
uh i need to just listen to the song so
i can cycle it out and get out of my
head hey i'm so glad you're with us on
this show we talk about mental health
relationships and
um
short-term memory
dysfunction which i seem to be
experiencing
because song popped in my head i thought
for the first time in a while evidently
not
so say you
but we're so glad you're here if you
want to be on our show give me a call
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask and let's go right to the phones
let's go to
jim in atlanta
georgia what's up brother jim
hi dr john how are you i'm good man how
are you
i'm doing great thanks for taking my
call
you got what's up all right hold on you
got it
dude i don't even know i was feeling
great today i got all my breathing
exercise like i'm feeling great i just
my words aren't working or am i singing
or my memory i feel that other than
those three things i'm all cylinders so
what's up man
um so
uh i've got a really good friend whom
i've known for
13 years now and we've served in
ministry together
i'm still in ministry
he works at a daycare now
and
there's some indication that he might
have
pedophilic attractions
um
and i just don't know how to handle that
as his friend
hmm
so i'll start first by saying thank you
for this call i appreciate that
and
recognizing that something needs to
happen you don't know what to do
yeah and i'll follow it up with
what are you doing man yeah
um like what what's the what's the hold
up like what's the i don't know like
where are you getting stuck
it's
the way i see it is that there's a lot
of yellow flags but i haven't seen like
a red flag yet
um and believe me if i knew that there
was
like a surefire like something had
happened all the cops right oh of course
no doubt about it all right good good so
what makes you think like give me some
examples of
has he told you this stuff have you
seen him looking at things on the
internet that he should i mean how do
you
what's causing you to think he might
have some tendencies along these lines
sure um about three years ago we were
having a really kind of vulnerable
conversation about
about stuff and struggle and everything
um
and uh he mentioned that he had
previously dealt with a pornography
problem
which is awful but it's not exactly rare
right it's something that a lot of us
have gone through but
it's the opposite of
rare yes right yeah yeah very common um
but
when i when he started sharing some
details he said that
the subject matter was beginning to
scare him and he used the words
younger and younger to describe what was
happening okay
um now that's not exactly uh you know
confession
but it was some it was a that's a yellow
flag for me and then ever since then
i've been noticing some things that
with that filter just don't sit right
with me and give me an example
so
he works at this daycare
he becomes really fixated on specific
kids in his class it seems
so much so that he
will break the rules and he'll take
pictures appropriate pictures but he'll
take pictures of them and save them oh
hell no dude
jim
we don't have any these aren't yellow
flags
okay okay
now yeah a buddy confessing to you three
or four years ago that man i like
looking at naked people and the naked
people i like looking at are getting
i'm trending towards a younger thing
that's a
vulnerable moment that somebody being
honest with you that in and of itself
doesn't indicate anything
right but as you said now you've got
that lens on you're wearing a pair of
glasses that he handed you right
and now you are going to rightfully sew
view things
uh view his actions through that lens so
let's have another one let's say he
leans over to you one day and y'all are
having vulnerable bro time do y'all
drink ipas it just feels like an ipa
conversation
no he does i do once in a while but i'm
more of a mixed drink kind of all right
thank you thank you grown up uh all
right so
um
so
let's say he's y'all are having one of
your
ipa mixed drink in the evenings and he
says hey i really have this weird thing
for wanting to hook up with other
people's wives
and you were like oh that's strange
explore and he's like well it's kind of
a
power thing like i want to be i want
them to i mean like he just goes down
this weird fantasy he's got i even call
it weird i just he's got a fantasy i'm
not even going to judge you it just is
what it is
then you show up next week and he's
sitting by your wife with his arm around
her and they're just laughing
uh
you would immediately go
hey homie
back that thing up you know what i mean
and not in the way that song was
originally written right you would tell
him hey like you and me are going to
parking lot right or you're not going to
fight him but you'd get right in the
middle of that
yeah and so
you don't want your friend to be a
pedophile
no
your friend is taking pictures of
children that he works with after
telling you
i'm really
i'm really finding myself increasingly
turned on by kids and i can think of
no greater
um
i have deep compassion for somebody that
finds himself in a situation where they
find
children attractive in a sexualized way
and my heart breaks for them what a
tortured life right because there's so
much joy with kids so much wonder so
much love i i do have compassion for
them and
i'll be damned if they're gonna ever
ever
hurt a kid on my watch
absolutely right and so
you've got other examples what's another
example here
that makes you uncomfortable
yeah so um
he
he and i are in kind of like a friend
circle and
his uh his siblings are a part of that
as well
and they have kids
sometimes just the way
that he interacts with their
uh one of their daughters just makes me
feel
just
uneasy um
certain kind of lap sittings and
hugs and kisses type thing that and i
and i'm having a hard time discerning
whether or not like
am i feeling weird about this because of
that filter or is this actually pretty
normal and there's all of that stuff
that i'm just like i don't know and then
there's uh
um
he part of the story is that he
confessed to someone else some of this
all kind of vague
um and then he said that he underwent
some counseling for it but i think that
ended up just being like a guy at church
and
yeah and that's and so my my question
though is like
i think it's falling upon me to have
this conversation with him and i just
don't know how to
even approach it all right so
um my
there's a great um i saw it on the on
the interwebs it was it really brought
joy to my heart um i think we talked
about on the show kelly i think you
don't want to send it to me but it was a
a dad
posted he was walking out of a store
and he was holding his daughter and
like i don't remember was like tj maxx
or something and she wanted to
grab some of the stuff that he'd say
keep your hands off of it she throws a
fit so he's carrying her out of the
store by one leg or something over his
shoulder and she's just having a a
walleyed temper tantrum and he's getting
her out of the store and she's screaming
and a man is walking into the store and
stops him in the parking lot
and says honey are you okay and she says
no i'm not okay
and my this man or my daddy is hurting
me or whatever and finally the dad
explains it the dad went on to post on
the internets
thank you
to this man
for seeing something that he thought
didn't sit right with him and calling it
out i'd rather err on the side of hey
young lady is this man hurting you then
not say anything see something weird
right so
any time it comes to kids
this is my personal rules my wife's
person any time i'm i see something
unsavory with kids
i'm gonna err on the side of saying
something
every time 100 times and if you are the
kind of person that me
that you see me asking you a hard
question or feel me or hear me asking
you a hard question about your
relationship with a child or children
and you don't that doesn't raise my
your respect for me but in fact you're
like oh dear you you bro then dude i
want nothing to do i don't have time for
you in my life
all right yeah so that's that's the lens
with which i look in the world okay
that's the way how to how i operate no
i'm not better than anybody else i'm not
like trying to line up like i just have
a thing about people hurting kids oh
like absolutely yep you know what i mean
so
i would be call your friend and you all
set up a time just you two no
embarrassment no anything and
i would be very very direct
and i would also put a
cap on it and so here's what i mean by
that
a few years ago brother you told me you
were struggling with x y and z it's also
i've heard through somebody that you
confide in somebody else you got
counseling for this stuff fine
i'm super uncomfortable with the way you
interact with your nieces and nephews
especially your nieces the way they sit
on your lap the way
there's something that feels sexualized
about that dude what are you talking
about i would never stop i'm talking and
you can respond when i'm done
when i found out you were taking photos
of kids in your daycare center that's
enough it's over yeah
you're gonna resign from this position
here
and you and i are gonna go sit you're
gonna fess up and let me know where you
are
and if there
you know what i think you let him know i
am gonna have to contact the authorities
on this i i i'm willing to lose the
friendship over protecting these kids
but i don't feel like they're safe
yeah and i think you i might
my initial thought is since you're not
looking at a smoking gun here is to say
you resigned from this job today
but my fear is he goes all right you're
right and then he's confirmed it and
then you need to get the police involved
right right yeah um
or he's like no way dude what are you
talking about and
you're in the same boat i think you let
him know hey this is coming um i have
reported this
and you're gonna have to resign and if
i'm wrong i'm sorry
but what i'm seeing with these kids i
just can't accept yeah okay
and man he goes through an investigation
he's found there's nothing on his
computers there's nothing on his phones
there's nothing at home nothing like
that
um
then he's vindicated you're vindicated
and i think you'd be honest with him and
say
i understand that you might feel like
this is a violation of our friendship
you might feel like x y
but i'm protecting these kids and i'm
protecting you
and
here's the thing this is you handling a
problem that you didn't start and so i
don't want you to feel like um
not if but when this thing goes sideways
which it will you know right and if you
have a friend group then his brothers
and sisters are gonna be like i can't
believe you accused him all that stuff
and let's be honest if it's true they
know
right they know they've been
uncomfortable or seen some things or you
know what i mean
um
but it's just not worth the risk for
those kids and you had dude the smoking
gun for me is taking pictures of kids at
a daycare
yeah i worked with i was an elementary
school teacher for you it never even
crossed my mind to take a photo
right you know what i mean
yeah i worked with high school kids and
they would give me a picture like
they're
like they're you know they're
they get a packet of photos you know
their yearbook pictures they'd bring
those to me and i was uncomfortable with
that
yeah what i mean those are high school
kids they were great i mean and i was
like ah you know what i mean
and so
anybody taking photos of children
uh come on man i mean you know what i
mean hey absolutely can you be honest
with me for one second
sure there's a big one you haven't told
me what's the big one
well
um
i think
so i have actually brought this up with
his siblings yep
and
they
kind of confirmed that they had the same
thoughts without a smoking gun as well
um okay dude all of y'all are smelling
smoke the house is on fire
yeah
that's a good landslide
hey everybody smell like i just can't
see the flames i guess we're coolest
just keep watching tv do the house on
fire yeah everybody smells it
yeah
cool and maybe if you've got a great
relationship with them tell them it's
coming
sure do they know about the photos at
the daycare center and all that they
know about all of it and they have tried
to look into stuff themselves and it
seems like they'd rather not deal with
it honestly
this is their kid
i know and what it seems like to me
though is that they
because there's
no slam dunk here they feel like well
we're just either being paranoid and
there's a in whatever struggle he is
going through the phrase that they use
that they found out that there's an
action plan in place
and i'm like i don't know what that
means that doesn't make me feel any
better here's the action plan i'm
calling the cops
yeah and i'd call a detective a
non-emergency detective and say i've got
some pretty clear indicators this is
happening families confirmed it
um now i've heard these taking photos of
kids or i've seen the photos of kids or
he's told me about them and um i'm
throwing a red flag on this one we need
someone to go investigate this
okay yeah and i'd probably contact i'd
contact him and let him know he's got 10
hours to resign he needs to resign today
get out of there today quit yeah i don't
care i don't care anything he's acquit
today um
and here's the thing he may go take his
life
that's that's another thing i'm really
afraid of he might he might
i need you to hear me say that's not on
you
the fear and i know it's easier to say
right it's easy to just throw that out
there you're like okay cool well cool i
know it's harder than that
um
but
you can't control what happens
next what you can control is right now
in the now right and that is i'm
stepping up because no other adult in
this unbelievable situation like i can
feel my blood pressure going up right
now
i even did my little fancy breathing
techniques this morning before i got on
the air and i'm still feeling i'm still
feeling him rise like somebody's got to
step in should be this kid's parents i
mean the kids the parents of imagine
just seeing you have kids
i don't know okay i'm just i've got a
six-year-old little girl
yeah dude i'm just
if i'm just imagining her sitting on
some man's lap and getting that feeling
like
nope
nope you know what i mean
um yeah anyway we could talk about this
all day man i don't want to belabor the
point today today and i don't know what
you have on your docket today it's
canceled cancel it man call them and say
dude i cannot go another day with i i'm
stepping in the middle of this on behalf
of these kids and if i'm wrong so be it
i'll find some other friends to have
mixed drinks with and that's one less
ipa drinker you have to hang out with
how about that that's the silver lining
here jim um hopefully his brothers and
sisters will stand up and say
thank god yeah we didn't have the
courage to do it or what's gonna happen
is we're gonna find his laptop and
everybody's gonna be vomiting
um and rightfully so because they should
have stepped up a long time ago today's
the day my brother sorry you're in the
middle of this but i'm grateful that
you're in the middle of this cause
somebody's gotta do something about it
and you're the guy we'll be right back
on the doctor john dolone's show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change save yourself the headache
and call churchill mortgage today at
triple h loan 200. trust me that's
triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back my blood pressure
is down a little bit more let's go to
mary in
seattle home of allison chains what's up
mary
hey how are you dr john i'm good how are
you
good now my blood pressure is up
oh you heard that last call
yeah slightly um
so what's up so
we just bought a farm we my husband oh
you and your family my husband okay
great yep
and my husband is gone during most of
the kids awake hours
so my question is how do we survive this
and find balance between
family life church and
the farm
oh man so tell me about this transition
to buy a farm why'd y'all guys buy a
farm
my husband has been a dairy farmer his
entire life
he went to school to study
agriculture
and
it's been his dream his entire life and
we finally
were able to do that
and it's been it's it's been a difficult
transition and i also
struggle with
being jealous of other families that are
living normal lives
because he works every day of the week
every single day there's been a big push
there's been a big push across the
country you know the last like with hdtv
and all these little
like build your own uh
you know uh
secret home in the wilderness
shows on youtube and stuff that people
have flocked out there and i did the
same thing i don't have a farm i just
got five or six acres
it's a lot of work
like it's yeah the chickens gotta be fed
every day and they gotta be let out
every day and the dogs have to be this
and whatever yeah so you gotta fix the
fence every week and so
it's a lot it's a lot more work than
people think when you say you're jealous
of normal people do you wish you were
living in the suburb in a 4-3 just no in
the life
no i just
like i'll see
somebody's
husband sledding with their kids on a
weekend and i'm like ah okay do you
realize how lucky you are oh man yeah
that's how i feel and it
i i keep hearing that this is the life
of a farmer's wife
and
do i suck it up deal with it
or do i
do i be the change
mary you're drowning
i my husband also has a very strong work
ethic so
i think there are times where
it is good it's a blessing but
i believe there are times where
he can come home
but he just doesn't know how to turn it
off he's like well i also should do this
and this and this and this
what is it about home that isn't a safe
place for him
i don't i don't think it's a
let me say that in a different way let
me ask you for not that you've made a uh
unsafe house for him that's how i'm
trying to imply
um
sometimes
not sometimes we naturally all lean
towards
the things that we feel that we are the
best at
and
if i know i can fix a tractor
i'm going to sit out there and keep
working on this tractor and it's got to
get fixed anyway right i don't have the
money to pay somebody so that's but i
know how this thing works i'm gonna keep
leaning into that
is there a
reality that he knows if he goes back
inside
he doesn't really know how to deal with
the five-year-old and i don't know how
old your kids are but that there is a
lack of efficacy there
and there's some shame there's some
uh
like i
i should know how to do this because i'm
a dad and so i'm just gonna wrap my dad
up in making sure everything's taken
care of at the farm and wife will take
care of the kids you know what i mean
like there's this lack of efficacy there
i think he definitely feels some guilt
to an extent because
he has mentioned that when he's coming
home he wonders if me and the kids will
still be there yeah not because i have
made threats
i i've been trying really hard to be
supportive of this
endeavor
but
i i am the one that disciplines the kids
and
raises them right it's we have a four
and a half and a two-year-old oh man
okay
and
and you're lonely up there
yeah
i mean i i have good friends that make
an effort to come over and they're
willing to
the kids along with me but
it definitely i'm a people person i need
people around me all the time
and so
and a four and a half year old and a
two-year-old and a couple of goats won't
cut that right
and you know it's
it's a lot of cows a lot of cows can i
can i poke one one step further
yep do you find yourself
really annoyed with him and really
annoyed with these kids
and you just want to have people and
then you feel guilty that you feel
annoyed
yes i get i feel very guilty yes because
you're supposed to be the farmer's wife
you're supposed to be the mom that just
loves being with their kids and what
and sometimes you just want to leave
them and go to a starbucks in a city and
hang out with your friends i do i
sometimes want to just run away and come
back later that day but
um
i i feel guilty
getting a sitter and leaving and i feel
guilty when i
am gone in the morning if i go out to
coffee with someone with the kids i feel
guilty when i don't bring food to the
farm and
i i try really hard to set
the note on a positive note when he
comes in but there are definitely times
when it's
he comes in
hours
after he said he would and i i am kind
of annoyed you should be
you're right you're right to be annoyed
so
here's a how long how long ago did y'all
buy this farm
two months
okay so we're this isn't a couple of
years you're 60 days in right
yep okay which we also have had
like every weather extreme you can think
of right you bought it you bought a farm
in the middle of the winter
right
but he has been
he was managing a different farm
and
um
i know what it's like being married to a
farmer i i think i know what it's like
by now
well
tell me about your marriage before you
bought this farm
were things heading in this direction
anyway not that your marriage is bad but
were they heading in this way anyway
no um
the last two years were a bit of a
struggle i
lost my little brother
and
i'm sorry i hit um that that's that's a
whole different
thing but i i just think i hit
my lowest point
and he was unsure how to
deal with that because he's never
he's never dealt with anyone that
struggled with mental health there you
go
is that even mental health that's grief
that's a deep deep black yeah and i
think
like i don't think he ever even
properly grieved the loss of him it was
yeah i don't know it was
so here's a here's a here's the thing
that happens it's quite common
okay
so you
have a deep loss
and the guy you've tethered your life to
doesn't handle it in the right way let's
just call it what it is
and part of you
raises an eyebrow to that
he's not exactly what you needed to him
to be in that moment
and you we don't have a playbook for
that
right it's it's similar not exactly but
it's similar to finding out somebody
maybe wasn't cheating on you but was
having a
texting thing with somebody at work
right it's
oh i didn't
i thought you would be there and you
weren't
or i thought you were this and you're
not
and we often don't have a playbook for
that and that one little splinter
whether it's a little splinter or a big
one and here's the thing i've done this
in my own house by the way
i didn't respond well to my wife's grief
and
i tried to expert her i tried to give
her a bunch of lectures and a bunch of
data points and i
blew it
and what i didn't realize was how deeply
i hurt her and how deep our our
the fracture in our relationship went
and the healing that had to happen there
began with her
bravery saying
i'm still not okay and this happened a
long time ago i'm still not okay
and i had to hear it and i had to take
it because it was right
and that that one act of bravery and
vulnerability
allowed me and her to then say where are
we now
and i had set up this future i mean this
dream for us mine was to be a college
president it wasn't to own a farm but
being a college president requires you
to do this and you do that and you run
all hours of the night and you're a part
of this committee and that committee and
you're on this thing with the city and
you're getting another degree in that
like it's that same life it's just with
a suit on instead of with dickies on
right
hopefully you're in seattle hopefully he
wears filson every day right like i got
he's very filthy
no filson like the
oh oh no no no not there somewhere else
but okay so
anyway he
ultimately it was is this the life this
is the life we said we wanted we're
getting closer to it is this really who
we want to be and the answer ultimately
was no
in that season the answer was no
and so you're two months in did y'all
take out a bunch of debt to buy this
farm
yep deal in the hole yeah so you're
scared financially you're all alone
you got a guy that you have trust issues
with not because you think he's cheating
on you i
i don't want to make him sound like he's
terrible he's not
he's me
he was there for me
when we were like
when we when we lost my brother it was
just the aftermath of
me
going back mentally to
a place where he has never been part of
my life right so hear me say mary and he
was very confused yeah i'm not talking
bad about him at all not even a little
bit i'm him
like we're the same guy okay
and i i know my heart through the whole
thing was was was good i know what i was
trying to do was good i knew i was
leaning into the things that i knew i
could do well and when i didn't know how
to connect with my wife because i felt
the gap i just didn't know what it was
i started leaning into the things that i
was good at which was work
which was helping other people with
their problems in the middle of the
night which was running around police
officers and with
marginalized population i mean i started
running around that way because i knew i
could be successful there
and what happens is over time that golf
because it's bigger and bigger and
bigger so in no way am i saying he's a
bad guy in fact i think the opposite i
think he's a great guy
i think you're great and i think he's
great and i think you're
both have pictures of what the other
person should be doing or you both have
pictures of what you thought your life
would be and now here it is and it's not
what you want
and that's okay
the problem is most of us don't own
where we're coming from
and if we don't own the reality of where
we're sitting where we're coming from
what's happening right now in real time
we can't be about fixing it and what you
said haunts me
is this just the way this is should i
just suck this up
the number of wives i've talked to over
the years who just said well he just was
going to be a bank president so this was
kind of my life
i can't tell you how many people i've
talked to
i can't tell you how many men i've
talked to said well i mean
i mean i was just going to take the next
promotion right why would i not take the
promotion and suddenly they find
themselves in a job that they hate
at a place that they hate
making good money
and their life is
miserable right so
i want you to hear me say what you and
your husband are experiencing is super
common the challenge is you all went all
in financially you owe a lot of money on
this thing he's feeling a lot of
pressure you're feeling a lot of
pressure there's financial insecurity
there's trust and i don't say trust like
he's gonna cheat on you but trust or
you're gonna cheat on him but trust like
you've got stuff going on you got
secrets that you're keeping from him
about how hard this is and he's got
secrets he's keeping from you about how
much he misses y'all but he bought this
farm it was his dream now he's got to
make this thing work
and what i'm saying is you all need to
have a where are we now 60 day
conversation
you've got to say i'm not okay and you
got to give him permission to say
tell me you're not okay because i bet
he's if he came and said
we just spent a million dollars on a
farm
is it more than that
yeah yeah we spent more than a million
dollars on a farm
i don't think i love it or i can't do
all this by myself
or i knew this was gonna be hard but i
didn't realize i was gonna miss my
entire children's life
those are some conversations he needs to
be able to say out loud and he probably
doesn't have a
like a map for how to do that right so
no
so
i i want to continue being supportive
but i think i also need to
put my foot down
in some areas like him coming home for
dinner yes because
he
he will
i'll tell him that he'll come home for
dinner two nights and then he calls me
and says
i could cut drop everything and come now
and he always has to go back out in the
evening
or he says i could come in
and be done for the night at seven
o'clock and i can help put the kids to
bed and i know he will not make it in at
seven o'clock right so what we're
getting i don't want to be no no no
it's not about what you don't want to be
you're talking about integrity issues
now
you're talking about you said and i'm
holding you to your word
integrity like we have two kids you're a
part of their lives
and so i think there's a there's some
boundary conversations that need to
happen
which is you're a functioning part of
this home
i need you here i want you here not even
i need you i want you here the kids want
you here
and if we need to hire some help then
we'll hire some help even though we
can't afford it if we like whatever the
thing is fine
but this i gotta go back out till seven
maybe in a season right so i'm about to
launch a book i'm about to enter a
season that's going to be bonkers for
the next three or four months my wife
and i sat down we talked about it we
game planned it we got we got our
calendars out i talked to my kids about
it and i'm making sure that i loop back
around on some other time with my kids
right because they don't understand as
much as they're like yeah cool dad they
don't get it and that's not they
shouldn't they're kids
but
we are super intentional about what the
next season's going to look like and
this thing ends with a pretty long
vacation this summer
this ends with me and my wife going
somewhere this ends with the kids coming
us with us on a thing so
like there's a there's a light at the
end of the tunnel you don't have a light
at the end of the tunnel you just got
darkness and you're like ah so if you
look at it like i'm gonna put my foot
down
you're making your relationship miiverse
him
and you may have to get there with your
boundaries i'd much rather see you lean
in at the beginning and say hey i'm
struggling i'm not okay
i know what being a farmer's wife is
like i didn't know i was gonna be a
single parent
i miss you
i really miss you
the kids miss you
and i don't know what's going on at the
farm but we need to be have better
communication if you say you're going to
be in i need you here for dinner every
day
and i need when you get at dinner i need
you to be done for the day and not work
all through the night
and then we can get up and you can get
up and go again tomorrow i mean some of
those conversations are great but that's
talking about i put my foot down you
have to is different than i need you
here you're what i'm saying and he may
say sorry honey i just can't do it well
then you cros that's when you say okay
well here's my boundary and then you're
gonna have to have your or what
conversation with yourself
which is or what am i gonna leave i'm
gonna take these kids and say nope we're
gonna be around people and other things
you don't want us in your life anyway so
we're gonna go ahead and move on
or you're gonna say no i'm gonna suck it
up and this is gonna be the rest of my
life
and my hope is yeah i don't get there i
don't think he's that kind of guy
do you no he's not i don't either it
sounds like he's a guy who doesn't know
how to start this conversation and a
gift would be
for you to start it with him
okay okay maybe you say hey here what's
three things you love about our new farm
what are three things that are killing
you about the new farm and you go first
and that gives him a way to lean into it
a little bit you know what i mean
yeah
you'll sound completely disconnected
[Music]
are y'all still holding hands and
looking at each other and smiling or is
it just all been work work work work
work
when we see each other
we
we don't see each other
that often and
i i mean
we
if we do go out to date night or
whatever he is pretty tired yeah he's
he's
pretty burnt out so okay so i think
there's something about first fruits
family family gets family gets the best
of you
where it gets part two
and i know that's not a popular saying
these days but
like
if all i give my family is whatever
little bit i've got left after giving my
all at work
um
then my family will never know me
my kids will never be tethered to
anything firm
my wife will not know affection and care
and love and vice versa it happens with
the other way around too
[Music]
so it's time for a hard conversation
that i hope you can have in love and
hope you can have with the spirit of
we're in this together and if you both
say let's sell the farm
like we're going to be lost
we're going to lose it all or whatever
let's sell the farm
sell the farm
fill the farm
your marriage is more important than the
farm your kid's more important in the
farm than some dream
sometimes that dream we've had for a
long long time turns out to be a
nightmare
he's lucky to have you he's lucky to
have you we'll be right back on the
doctor john elon's show
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
if you pre-order today you'll get over
several hundred dollars of free bonus
items so go to johndaloni.com to take
the next step towards wellness that's
own your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back all right so
here we go i'm gonna do something a
little bit different but not really
so
it's i talked about this with some
regularity on this show i got a group of
experts all across the country i think
there's 20 now in the group
that are mental health professionals
they're professors they're researchers
and scholars they are practitioners who
are in the grinding out therapy hour
after hour after hour after hour
and they help me when kelly gives me a
heads up says hey we're getting a call
that's a diagnostic call about this or
about something else or we're dealing
with a young child with autism who's got
trauma and
i've got a friend who's an expert in
that so
one of the
cornerstones of this show is me saying i
don't have all the answers and but i
know somebody who does and i spend my
life cultivating people who i love and
respect and care for and who
are so generous with their time and
their wisdom and their expertise okay so
when it comes to mental health stuff we
got it when it comes to financial stuff
got it
um when it comes to breaks and how a car
works got it i've got people in my life
that help me with this
and so one of the things that i always
want to bring to the show
are
things that are perplexing questions to
me
and like i don't fully understand this
and i can google it all day and there's
so much garbage out there
and you all know that one of the
sponsors to the show is a mattress
company and the mattress like
it's incredible and it's awesome and the
reviews have come back have been working
oh that's great
but i kept being haunted by i keep being
haunted by this question
which is
feels like a couple years ago there was
a billion mattresses just hit the market
all of a sudden like when i grew up
there was just a mattress
and now you can have them shipped in a
box with
foam or springs and i got mattresses
with like cell phones built into them
that track your sleep and you can
sit at this height and if you start
snoring or farting it will raise or
lower you whatever's going on like these
things are
and so i just started like what is
happening
like we like a hundred years ago we were
sleeping on a corn cog like a bag full
of corn cobs
and now
we've got
tesla mattresses or whatever's going on
right
so
i reached out to bob munkel he is the
vice president of retail engagement of
resident home he owns he's the vice
president of retail engagement over a
big um
mattress conglomerate and
i just wanted to get some first-hand
knowledge you guys been in the business
for years and years decades and decades
and decades and i just want to have an
expert on here explain to me and
hopefully you'll find this interesting
as i do
um
what is happening
with mattresses what's the big deal
about them what is this all and it
sounds like a big long paid ad it's not
i'm getting no money for this talk okay
i just
got
fed up with i don't understand what's
going on so bob are you there
i am here john how are you well good
what's up brother b so listen uh i think
you heard my thing at the beginning here
i'm glad you're willing to take your
time today and walk
all of us through
dude what is happening with
with
mattress
usa it feels like it's bananas can you
walk us through like a quick history of
how we got from sleeping on a bag of
corn husks to
where we are now like like just the
the arc of mattress architecture what's
happened
so it is confusing of course and you're
right it all started with corn husks
and so on it really did i was just kind
of making that up i felt like i got that
from a disney movie or something
they used to take farm you know corn
husks and various things off the farm
and stuff bags
as tightly as they could and then uh you
know they used to sleep on that and then
over 100 years ago the inner spring more
or less was introduced into the mattress
industry and that that really
revolutionized things now you have to
manufacture these things and then you
know some years later latex foam had
come out which was really a
foam rubber if you will and then folks
slept on that and then all the the
polyols or the polyurethane foams came
and then memory foam was really
introduced in the mattresses in the late
80s into the 90s a very famous brand has
made that a uh
extremely popular and and now you have
you know you have gel technologies and
you have like i said you know you can
now track your sleep there are devices
that can actually track lightly deep
sleep rem sleep and then deliver a
report to your apple watch or to your
phone and it really has come a long way
but the two big things that are related
to this mattress in a box and this
explosion of mattress ads on your
screens is about you know over 20 years
ago roll pack technology these machines
that could actually take a mattress
compress it roll it and bag it to put it
in a box that's been around over 20
years but it wasn't popular popularized
by brands ads that you see what did
happen is you know as the internet grew
and it became in the hand of everyone
some very savvy marketers really in uh
after 2010 began to say hey
we can manufacture a mattress anywhere
we can put it in a box we can ship it
fedex ups dhl and get it to the front
door of anyone so now let's make a
mattress let's market it let's send
digital ads to your screens and now
suddenly there's an explosion of
companies that are really in the
mattress business utilizing the latest
and greatest sciences but and what
they're doing is they're roll packing
mattresses putting it in a box and
getting it to your front door really
bypassing a lot of the retail stores
some of the larger brands are now in
retail stores so you have the ability to
go online you know watch videos read
reviews you know get acquainted with
this brand this mattress its technology
its benefits but then go into a local
retail store
and try it before you buy it so it's
almost it's almost like the retail
stores had a monopoly on this for so
long then all of a sudden i i call them
the internet kids they may have been 80
years old i don't know internet kids
said forget you guys we're just going to
sell it directly and it's almost like
the
box stores then
basically be like had to get on board
and say well before you buy it you can
try it out you know i mean like it
almost is a reversal now to where i
there was a wave like in 2010 i think
that's about right when people i knew
the idea of buying a mattress on in in
the mail was preposterous it was just
luna who would do that why would you do
that
it was and then there was a season from
yeah about 2010 to 2018-19
when
everyone i knew just ordered them and
then i they started falling apart they
didn't last like so there became issues
with it and now i guess people are going
back and trying them out so
help me with sleep architecture here
um
and i know you're not like a
phd sleep scientist here but walk me
through
the
what's the difference between like a
firm mattress and i've got a family
member that they've got a mattress
that's basically like sleeping on like a
driveway
um it's the least comfortable thing ever
created by any human ever
but i got some family members that think
it's the greatest thing ever and then my
bed is basically um like my preference
is somewhere in the hammock region right
is there a
an up or down to
mattress softness or firmness or does it
matter is it just preference does one
help you sleep better than the other
what's what's the deal with that
so the level of firmness in a mattress
uh it does not really determine how long
a mattress will last or how supportive
that mattress may be for your body
really and comfort is comfort is truly
personal preference let me give you an
example
think of the comfort of a mattress
as the surface of the mattress and think
of the support of the mattress as below
that the base of the mattress because
they're really two distinctly different
things and they deliver different
benefits so let's give you an example so
you kneel down on a hard floor that is
noticeably firm
but what if he took a pillow and put it
on the floor now you kneel down still
firm but a little less so what if you
took three pillows put that down on the
floor now it's considerably less firm
but yet you have not changed the
firmness of the floor
so we as many mattress manufacturers we
can design various different support
systems that will provide the
conformance
and the positive resistance that your
body needs to be properly aligned while
you sleep so your muscles can relax if
you're restored but then we can change
the ingredients on top of those support
systems to make it feel softer for your
personal preference or even firmer
so it's not the hardness in a mantra
stat will determine its support it is
the actual support system down below but
we can make that support system feel
softer we can make that support system
feel medium firm we can make that
support system feel very firm so comfort
is truly personal preference oh i knew
it i knew okay good so i
i didn't know that about the softness
and about the firmness but the stability
of it but i
have been told that um
i've got weird i'm weird and you just
made me feel less weird so thanks for
that bob um
how do you know so i mean conventional
wisdom would say that when this thing
starts getting saggy or you can start
seeing body imprints in or something
it's it's it's dead and it's time to get
a new one that sounds like that may not
be the case how do you know when a
mattress is done when it's cooked
um
okay so that's a classic question first
off the mattress does not have to be old
in order for it to stop meeting your
needs
some mattresses wear out more quickly
sometimes our body changes john
and our knees from the mattress are you
talking about weight gain bob
i i'm not i'm not making any reference
at all i'm suggesting is that sometimes
our bodies change over time
and some of those changes could be even
temporary such as pregnancy etc
uh but what happens is the demand that
we make on that mattress may change over
time so the mattress does not have to be
old in order to say all right it's time
for a new mattress sometimes it's no
longer meeting your needs so how do you
know well here are the key things the
key benefits that a mattress produce for
the human body are comfort
then support which is body alignment and
finally sleep surface temperature
so all of these things can create
problems in sleep that can rob us of the
healthy sleep we need in order to be at
our best such as rem sleep the dream
stage or even deep sleep that restores
your human body disruptions in sleep
will rob you of the rem sleep and deep
sleep you need so how would you know
does it take you a long time to fall
asleep
are you tossing and turning is that
waking you up is that disrupting your
sleep are you waking up with any back
pain soreness fatigue
in the morning and it saves after about
an hour or so uh are you sleeping too
hot or too cold you know you're sticking
the leg out the leg comes back in covers
off covers on all these things are
disruptions of sleep that will rob you
of healthy sleep and their clear
indications that it's time for a new
mattress that current mattress is no
longer meeting your needs so you would
um so i sleep with a especially in the
in the summer months i sleep with a
um
a temperature device it's it's a like a
mattress topper that just cycles cold
water through it and yeah um
i won't say their name here but
the the
so temperature matters all those things
are important um
how do we know if it's just like not our
room is too hot or like man i've put on
20 pounds i need it's not really the
mattress's fault as much as i need to
you know how do you know that the
balance between all those things you
mentioned are good variables to for a
good night's sleep i hesitate to blame
it all on the mattress how do i know
when no the mattress is helping cause
these problems
the um well
as it relates to comfort and support it
is the mattress okay when it as it
relates to temperature though we have
uh we the sleeper have substantial
control over temperature so i'll give
you an example
um
if we're sleeping too hot or too cold
let's assume you say you're sleeping too
hot what if we took the covers off you
no longer had covers right
all you have is sleep clothing well you
may turn around and say well now i'm
sleeping cold but you haven't changed
the mattress
so what happens is we as sleepers the
human body actually sleeps cold here's
the shocker every human being sleeps
cold because during deep sleep and rem
sleep our core body temperature goes
down by as much as two degrees that's
just a human fact so we all sleep cold
and what we do is we compensate john
through sleep clothing you know you may
know them as jammies or whatever you
want to call them right and then we have
seats so we have blankets we have quilts
and comforters and all this stuff and
what we do is we we get into bed
right and initially look like we could
be cold right and then we create this
micro climate we cocoon ourselves with
these various coverings to trap our own
body heat because we're the source of
heat there and then if that gets too
much we get too hot
so what happens is you know if you peel
off covers if you change your your sleep
clothing if you change your blankets
your quilts or whatever you can really
micro adjust that this micro climate
that you've created for yourself and
have an ideal sleep temperature but it
is true
that some mattress materials have a
tendency to reflect body heat back to
you rather than whisk it away and manage
it away from the body excellent yeah
that's one of the things i've loved
about
the
the mattresses that we support here are
um
man is that they sleep a little bit
cooler than the other mattresses i've
i've slept on so which is which is super
cool all right hey i gotta run bob dude
thank you so much for calling um for
calling in and giving up your morning
here i'm really grateful to get to talk
to some sort of sleep expert to help me
figure out the how this stuff works man
so grateful you gave us a couple of
helpful tips on what is important about
how sleep works i mean things that are
important like temperature comfort
stability
and
when to know when a mattress is up so
thank you so much for your expertise
there hey everybody we'll be right back
on the dr john deloney show
hey i received this email the other day
this is from nicole and here's what she
writes dr dalony my toddler slept
through the night for the first time in
months on his new dream cloud mattress
he said it was so
cozy he has the best mattress in the
house totally worth it for more sleep
thought i'd share thanks nicole good
folks i'm receiving notes like this from
all over people who said it is time for
me to start getting better sleep for
their kids to start getting better sleep
people are saying i want my whole family
to change everything and change begins
with a good night's sleep it is time to
stop sleeping on the mattress you got on
that online marketplace or it's time for
your kids to stop sleeping on a fourth
generation bedroom set on a mattress
that existed before we landed on the
moon and yes we did land on the moon and
look i've made it easy for you dream
cloud is running their biggest offer
ever for dr john daloni show listeners
almost 400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 cash discount that's a
total of
650 bucks in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protector sheets and
they deliver it all to your house
change your life change your kid's life
change your family's life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com daloni or go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney and get
your new mattress and enjoy your savings
today
all right we are back all right as we
wrap up today's show
kelly it's good to see you benjamin
james
nate doggy dog donkey dog doggy dog it's
good to see
everybody chris who is basically james's
new boss he sent in this song and so we
have to do it there you go chris
i don't have never even heard of this
band well done chris the band is
passenger and the song is
feather on the clyde this already sounds
creepy but i'll continue
well there's a river that runs through
glasgow oh great it's an ireland song
well there's a river that runs through
glasgow and it makes her but it breaks
her and takes her in two parts in a
current just like my blood flows down
from the hills around aching bones to my
restless heart well i would swim but the
river is so wide and i'm scared i won't
make it to the other side well god knows
i failed but he knows i've tried i long
for something that's safe and warm move
to tennessee dude but all i have is
all that is gone i'm as helpless and as
hopeless as a feather on the clyde
chris i think you should call into the
show
i think we've got some help for you
and you too america we'll see you soon
on the dr john dolan show